another day another failed attempt to
execute scp-682
the infamous hard to destroy reptile the
most recent attempt was scp-272
an old iron nail with the ability to pin
people's shadows to the ground and tear
them to shreds when different
configurations of light makes their
shadows go haywire just when it seemed
like 272 and a high-powered disco ball
might be the thing to win the
foundation's war against the
misanthropic lizard it did what it
always did pulled out a trump card and
ruined everything its body evolved a
sudden intense bioluminescence that
completely eliminated the beast's shadow
by overpowering all other light sources
in the room this not only rendered the
foundation's strobe lights utterly
useless but blinded several members of
d-class personnel who were sent in to
check on the beast during testing this
resulted predictably in another big fat
l for the scp foundation 682 435
foundation 0
and nobody was more frustrated than dr
samet samett was a foundation greenhorn
with big ambitions like every jerk at
the office he was less concerned with
doing his job right and far more
concerned with climbing the corporate
ladder summit had done all he could cozy
up to site directors and even the
overseers far above all with the goal of
someday getting a seat at their high
table but as any scp fans know they're
not just giving out positions on or just
under the o5 council to swing something
like that you need to really make an
impression you need to wow them and what
would be a better way to do that than
being the person who killed scp-682
surely if he had actually buried that
beast they'd hand him the keys to the
proverbial castle so dr samut had done
everything he could to get reassigned to
the 682 termination effort and only now
was he realizing just how in over his
head he truly was dr sammit needed help
from a higher power if he ever hoped of
beating
scp-682 the man needed god on his side
thankfully they just so happened to have
god chilling out in his containment cell
in site-17 perhaps through enlisting the
help of earth's divine arbiter he could
bring an end to the scourge of scp-682
and rocket himself to success in the
process however while dr samet may have
been arrogant he wasn't completely
delusional he knew he didn't have the
standing to address scp-343 directly
much less to ask him for a hand in
destroying scp-682
he'd need a go-between someone with
tenure someone who commanded respect
among scp foundation staff as well as
the very anomalies they governed perhaps
someone who was a little bit anomalous
themselves and who better fits this
description than the living legend dr
jack bright dr samut had of course read
the doctor's personnel files everybody
at the foundation knew about dr bright's
exploits from what he's done to the
various things he isn't allowed to do
which we'll cover in a future video he's
also dug up the scp-963 files the
anomalous medallion keeping dr bright
alive whether he likes it or not while a
discussion of the exact nature of the
medallion isn't something you'd want to
have in front of dr bright himself after
all it is a touchy subject you could
make the argument that the medallion is
the real hymn it is where his soul is
condemned to spend perhaps the rest of
eternity killing and stealing the body
of anyone or anything that touched it
he'd become an immortal parasite
destined to take the finite lives of
others while his own marches on forever
remind you of anyone dr samet got into
contact with dr bright and explained his
plan with bright's help he'd recruit
scp-343
and bring the very wrath of god down
onto the hard-to-destroy reptile of
course while dr samut naturally assumed
himself to be the smartest person in the
room dr bright had a more realistic
assessment of the ambitious young turks
skills he saw sammit for what he truly
was a climber a butt kisser a greedy
power-hungry bureaucrat wearing a lab
coat and he thought that made him a
researcher
it was laughable what dr wright found
less funny though was dr samut's
insistence on calling him scp-963
there's a lot to know about dr bright
but one thing you should definitely
commit to memory is that you should
never under any circumstances call dr
bright scp-963
and if you were forever entwined with a
necklace that doomed you to watch
everyone you know and love age and die
while depriving you of that same release
you'd probably resent being associated
with it too dr bright did agree to
participate in dr samet's hair brain
termination scheme but with a warning
that he did not give lightly if ever dr
samut called him 963 again he would have
one of his own loyal team members
nicknamed the lucky bunch for their high
survival rate compared to other
foundation research teams shoot him in
the foot dr bright steeled himself and
entered 343's containment cell where the
playful deity had taken the form of the
late comedian george burns complete with
his trademark glasses and half-smoked
stogie they made small talk with 343
delivering his usual high-handed cryptic
parables about his plans for dr bright
and everybody else he even momentarily
teased the idea of freeing him from his
curse but dr bright knew better than to
buy into these fairy tales he talked
scp-343 into a cross test but didn't
tell him it was with 682 or that he was
expected to terminate it that was better
left as a surprise dr samut and dr
bright stood in the observation area
outside the cross testing chamber sammit
was giddy with excitement and confidence
in this new experiment dr bright's
reactions were a hell of a lot more
measured he'd been working at the
foundation long enough now to know that
terminating scp-682 was a fool's errand
the only researchers still intent on
trying it we're doing so out of
stubbornness and ego and when 343 and
682 were released into the chamber dr
bride's healthy pessimism was more than
justified 682 attacked a nearby door
attempting to breach containment while
343 looked around confused and seemingly
unable to see anything when he was
ordered to kill 682 he was shocked to
learn 682 was even in the room he
stormed off moments later in a huff
saying he's not one of mine deal with
him yourself
dr bright was unsurprised dr samet was
shocked and furious how could this have
failed they literally had god on their
side this setback would seriously
compromise his chances of rising through
the ranks unless he found a quick way to
make the best out of a bad situation and
save face without even thinking he
turned to dr bright and said fine it
didn't work doesn't matter get yourself
ready 963 you're going in so it was
decided dr bright himself would face off
with scp-682
in
scp-343's place dr bright was a betting
man he loved a good game of chance and
he estimated that his odds of succeeding
were exceptionally low but what would be
the point in refusing even if he
couldn't kill
scp-682 perhaps he would get lucky and
the reptile would kill him instead so
many enticing possibilities dr bright
left to prepare for the coming battle
and because nobody would say that dr
bright wasn't a man of his word he had
one of his assistants shoot dr samut in
the foot a few days later dr bright dr
samut now in a wheelchair while he
recovered from his unfortunate foot
injury and a collection of other
researchers including dr sophia light
were convened in a conference room
planning out their assault on
scp-682 a mechanical staff of sorts was
laying on the table in front of him a
kind of powerful taser capable of firing
out painful bolts of electricity it
would be the only object dr bright
carried into the chamber with him that
day but only as a way of getting 682's
attention not as a weapon the true
weapon was scp-963
the plan was simple
scp-682 would eat dr bright and the
power of
scp-963 would destroy it from within as
anyone with an awareness of 963's
anomalous properties could tell you for
most living beings touching the
medallion results in immediate brain
death followed by the consciousness of
dr bright inhabiting your mindless body
if they could get this phenomenon to
work for scp-682
perhaps with dr bright's mind in
scp-682's body could they now end the
life of this wretched beast once and for
all like with all matters involving
scp-682 and dr bright it was most likely
not going to be so simple when dr bright
entered the test chamber with 682 as dr
samut and the others watched from the
observation room the results were sudden
and violent dr bright zapped the monster
with his electro staff and it came
charging for him a terrible fury of
teeth and claws dr bright had died so
many times and yet he couldn't even
recall many experiences more unpleasant
than this and as 682's interior flesh
met
scp-963 dr bright woke up in the middle
of a strange new place there was a man
standing over him that looked oddly
familiar
except for the strange chainmail
hallberg he was wearing when dr bright
found his feet he recognized the man it
was a d-class in fact the first body
he'd ever inhabited after his soul fused
with scp-963
but he wasn't alone here there were so
many people all of them wearing the same
chain mail and carrying the same electro
staffs that dr bright had carried into
the chamber with him little by little he
recognized every single one of the faces
they were all people whose bodies he'd
taken whose lives he'd cut short to
further his own he looked around and saw
more bizarre sights a grand castle
structured like a deranged escher
painting and up above drowning out the
sky was a great reptilian behemoth like
scp-682 on steroids made entirely from
barbecue sauce the d-class broke the
surreal news none of this was real it
was a fantasy his mind had concocted to
help him cope with his consciousness
bonding with scp-682
a more palatable way of perceiving his
new reality and if he ever wanted to get
out and be himself again he would need
to fight and conquer the beast within dr
bright joined forces with his past
victims including one former level 2
researcher damian smith together using
their electro staffs bright and his army
of mental constructs blasted the great
monster in the sky from the safe
confines of the castle however things
weren't quite as safe as dr bright had
first imagined the massive creature
descended upon them tearing the castle
to shreds with its huge claws the
construct of damon smith was devoured in
the process dr bright's brief illusion
of victory was soon stifled by one
immutable fact you could not defeat
scp-682
he retreated from the monster into the
darkness of his own nightmares from
there he woke up dr bright was in a
hospital bed the medallion attached to a
new body after 682's body had rejected
it he was greeted by dr sophia light and
a member of the o5 council dr wright had
effectively been gone for days when he
asked what happened on the outside he
was told that 682 had entered a 36-hour
coma before growing massive claws and
tunneling out of containment where it
caused a massive breach though strangely
upon breaking out of the chamber it only
attacked one researcher and in unrelated
news dr samet had been taken off the 682
case it didn't take long for things to
return to normal for dr bright well as
normal as life can be when you're a man
as strange as him but while few would
notice it 682 was left altered it had
taken a souvenir from dr bright
fragments of the consciousness of damon
smith it felt his pain his fear it
tasted it dissected it and now
understood it and when the opportunity
presented itself once more as it always
did he couldn't wait to inflict it on
others now go check out scp-682 waze scp
foundation try to kill hard to destroy
reptile and how to kill
scp-682 theories and ideas for more
entries in the seemingly endless quest
to finally put
scp-682 in the ground for good